this is Startalk Bancroft coming to us
from Earth mm-hmm okay dr. Tyson in your
opinion who would be the most
scientifically accurate and believable
superhero with superhuman abilities in
relation to real-world physics and
counterpoint the most unbelievable and
inaccurate and why yes so he is coming
to us from Brisbane Australia oh cool
so I think the most reachable superhero
that's out there is Batman because he
uses real devices on his utility belt
sadly and there's nothing there you just
say oh that can't happen or you couldn't
have done that or you know yeah he's got
some some special materials but that's
okay
because his company makes a millionaire
yeah he's a billionaire and his company
is working for the government at
developing experimental technology and
he's got a religion who don't have
absolute so so for me is the most
realistic superhero and Robin as well
the he's just an acrobat in tights okay
all right so at least that's their cover
mm oh you know we know the deal hang
around with that young boy out of time
given under there
living into a house okay
billionaire mansion we made a deal we
know that you oh yes that's my young
warrior oh is that what you call him no
your young ward oh okay
okay child services won't be calm
because you're a billionaire and you
have a young ward okay let me do that I
am up on charges
I swear I've never thought about it that
way nor did I ever think that Bert and
Ernie were a gay couple you know just
you know there's a hole or the
tinky-winky was the gay one out of the
you know there's a hole there's a whole
literature on hood but right exactly who
and what might be good who and what my
mean
so will I forgot what I was talking
about so you were saying that most
realism right realistic is patent
he's more real than Ironman because the
energy source that Ironman is drawing
from to concentrate that much energy in
one place you would basically vaporize
everything it was touching back so and
and the other thing too is when you
think about tony stark having this power
source inside his chest right okay let's
be honest let's just hook him up to a
city and forget it because that's
amazing right why is this guy flying
around in a suit instead of powering New
York up free but go ahead
right so you can't concentrate energy
anything that you've ever used that has
a lot of energy going on with it gets
very hot very quickly
that's what energy does if you fire a
gun enough times the gun gets warm and
can't even get too hot to touch right
right
and cannons in the old days in fact they
used cannons firing cannonballs and the
fact that the cannon kept getting harder
and harder to discover and come to an
understanding of how heat worked the
physicists would say we while you're
fighting this war kid may be coming here
measure measure right measure and he
thought there was a substance called
caloric which was a fluid that would be
heat if you put caloric from one thing
to the other then that thing would be at
a higher temperature and so there was
early ideas were were we were
intellectually sort of mation ating how
this would work so so Tony Stark well I
think he could wipe the floor with
Batman right if I had to be one of those
I definitely be Tony Stark yeah because
you're both billionaire yes okay why not
right
well no they're both billionaire at
something right yeah the both yeah pick
one pick the billionaire you want to be
right right and so definitely but it's
the energy the concentration of energy
is not it's not real this is Startalk